this video was made possible by tab for
a cause raise money for charity just by
opening tabs what you were going to do
anyway link in the description 20-18 has
been a wild ride for lawyers so let's
take this opportunity to look back on
some of my favorite reactions from the
past year so a funny story that actually
happened to me in court and I also
punched the witness I'm getting then let
us begin with your opening statement mr.
hey whoa opening statement so how can
you give an opening statement and
summarize your case if you have no idea
what your case is or what the case is
about
there's no ways guilty but how will I
convince the judge do you not have have
you not spoken to your client and he's
apparently wearing the same thing that
he was wearing on the day of the murder
so it did it man I don't even know what
to do with that
perhaps we could reach as high as 50 75
with all due respect mr. Bracken this is
not a negotiation it's definitely a
negotiation this is the most highly
requested legal TV show from my mom I
bet the judge is gonna say all allowed
at some point in this hearing I
guarantee it after last custody hearing
Michael was pretty worried about
challenged action Your Honor on what
grounds hearsay
nice try mrs. Florrick all allowed go
ahead yeah called it upstairs yes that
secretary should definitely support an
attorney who is conducting an interview
of a criminal defendant that is going to
trump whatever it is that she was
working on at the moment and also I
don't know what she was supposed to do
with the deposition that's not something
secretaries do anyway all right so
Alicia's underwater I guess so on the
nights that you don't go out
you don't record the actual surveillance
image you set your computer up to
duplicate the night before just in case
your manager checks it is that correct
yes oh snap you got lawyers son so
you're wondering whether demolishing the
key prosecution witness didn't just save
your ass his first chair nice work by
the way Thanks it was enough for
reasonable doubt yes she didn't just
demolish the the prosecution's main
witness she showed him to be an outright
liar are we clear
crystal crystal did you order the Code
Red
I did the job damn right I did
I have never once seen a witness admit
to the crime or the civil act that they
are accused of on the witness stand
today we're tackling a fan-favorite
highly requested suits now I've never
seen a full episode of suits before but
I'm guessing from the title that it's
about a group of men who wear suits you
can tell I'm I'm very perceptive about
these things we got paid before Gerald
signed the deal are you talking about
this is a memo about some fire drill on
Tuesday you're the blue team captain you
get to wear a fire hat okay all right so
what this person has done is called
fraud so you're taking my promotion away
new most firms will put you in from the
bar and have your license stripped you
lied to a client and he figured it out
yes exactly
don't lie to a client you should not lie
to a client and defraud them this protip
don't lie to your client
I saw that that should be stricken well
what if hernan did come to you your
honor there's nothing to strike you
there's nothing on the record so I'm
gonna need to keep this thing moving are
you gonna bang the average hammer gavel
hammers calls gavel you'll be dealing
with me today and you'll be dealing with
me today Jack Kelly
lawyer good to see you again are those
fake hands no what is it the fake Hey
and my research shows that unlike your
typical North American barn swallow the
the Poconos small if kept under the
proper conditions does this have to do
with anything
how many bench warrants for sexual
misconduct do you have would there be
bench warrants for sexual misconduct I
don't think that's a thing how do we get
on evolution yes exactly
you shouldn't be talking about this at
all Oh Jay trial to that hero cop Mark
Fuhrman hotel not touching that one what
Charlie is trying to do here is to enter
character evidence on behalf of Frank
he's trying to say that Frank has a
character for lack of donkey brains
which is a ridiculous sentence for me to
have to say right now but anyway that's
what he's trying to do only problem is
they kept being wrong sometimes you fool
this is getting dangerously close to the
Chewbacca defense why would a Wookiee an
eight-foot-tall look want to live on
Endor with a bunch of two-foot tall
Ewoks that does not make sense but more
important you have to ask yourself what
does this have to do with this case
nothing right oh no I think I know where
this is going
no there's no resolution no oh my god oh
no all right this is a perfect example
of sometimes the evidence just speaks
for itself in Latin that's the phrase
race if loquitur the thing speaks for
itself
and frankly sometimes it doesn't require
any legal argument how would you like to
make a partner right now oh no oh no
quid pro quo sexual harassment
oh is it even consensual are we doing
this morning constant fine thank you
thank you mr. Reid I'm a little upset
about a bad sexual episode why don't we
just take it from them talk to the cubs
some more I fail to yield at a crosswalk
I changed lanes the intersection I
changed lanes without signaling while
running a red light at speeding is that
all no I have unpaid parking tickets
your driver's license not allowed to
enter the well like that the bailiff
will tackle you you know what this means
they're gonna keep coming after her
personally legally and whatever way they
can take it to the judge there will be
sanctions thank you oh god don't even
get me started about liquor licenses in
New York it's crazy you know what I like
about you know there's always something
going on what's redeemable about her
character know that she's done nothing
she seems like a blank slate that
everyone just projects what they want
onto her this is a serious crime when
you have witness tampering and you've
killed someone's dog I mean never mess
with someone's dog I lied this isn't a
past case but when I took last week
after Gina fire debate whether my law
students there
I won't know when I just screamed really
Oh Oh No
oh my god you can't have law students at
a witness interview it breaks the
attorney-client privilege
that's just screaming malpractice her
entire law class are not members of her
firm and they are not the attorneys for
this individual so by having literally
hundreds of people present for when this
person is talking that breaks the
privilege and anything that she is
saying right now can be used against her
it's discoverable and it may be
admissible in court this is awful this
is this is sanctionable and and she
should be disbarred immediately crazy
who else is going to save Santa Claus if
not for the lawyers they gave him a
subpoena well if you're going to call
the prosecutors son you have to subpoena
them hearsay so within the world of this
movie Kris Kringle has committed assault
and may be guilty of felony aggravated
assault in bhopping the psychiatrist on
the head with an umbrella Merry
Christmas
those were some great reactions but
there is one reaction I'd like from you
charity towards your fellow man and I
have a super easy way to do it tab for a
Cause is a Google Chrome extension that
allows you to pick a charity of your
choice and then every time you open up a
new tab instead of it being blank it
runs a couple of ads and the money
generated is donated to your charity
there is no charge to you and it
actually does some good for the world
tab for a Cause users have raised over
six hundred and fifty thousand dollars
for charity it's quick and super easy to
get started just click the referral link
in the description box below to download
the extension and do some good by doing
what you were going to do anyway it is
the easiest possible way to donate to
charity
so check out tab for a Cause by clicking
the link below and until next time I'll
see you in court